First of all, most people don't realize
how long it takes to learn a language.
Hi there, this is Steve
Kaufmann from Palm Springs.
Uh, today I'm going to talk
about problems, problems people
have in language learning.
Remember if you enjoy these videos,
please subscribe and they click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
First of all, why am I
talking about problems?
Because I, my whole filming set up
has, is giving me nothing but problems.
Last video, I had this reflection on
those prints that I have in behind me.
The time before that I filmed in front of
the curtain, which didn't look very nice.
I've ordered some hanging sort of
backdrops, but I haven't figured
out how to pin them up yet.
And then it'll at least looked
like some fake bookshelves.
Uh, Or I got another one
that's fake wooden planks.
Uh, but then I've ordered little skinny
bars so that my wife can sow a little
thing and we can hang it up there.
And then the lighting is all
messed up and it's not working.
And my filmic pro is giving me problems.
So I just got fed up with
it all, all my problems.
And I said, I'm just going to go
out in the garden and do it and
I'm going to talk about problems,
language learning problems.
What are the main problems that
I see amongst language learners?
I'm going to try to center
myself here again, problems.
First of all, most people don't realize
how long it takes to learn a language.
So people get frustrated.
They get particularly frustrated when
they get to that first level where
all of a sudden they know a bunch of
words and they realize just how little
they know of the whole language and
people get frustrated and they have
the sense that they're not progressing.
And maybe they think that everyone
else is learning and I'm not learning.
And I think that's where it's so
important to realize A that it's a long
process and B that you have to find
a way of doing it that is enjoyable.
So I don't worry about the fact
that I've been at Arabic and Persian
for a long time and there are other
people who learn faster than me.
I'm enjoying it.
I was listening to my Egyptian Arabic
mini stories that have been now rerecorded
by Adel of Alexandria and I was going
through the texts again and it's fun.
I enjoy it.
And I know that trickle,
trickle, trickle I'm improving.
So the first thing I find is a lot
of people don't have the patience.
Second problem is a lot of people,
and I find this myself too, you know?
So I'm doing the mini stories,
Adel's mini stories and I've gone
through two or three of them.
Uh, it's not like instantly I've
done something like I've built
something or made something happen.
I'm just doing this and I have to remind
myself that it is actually slowly,
the language is trickling into me.
So don't worry about doing something
else, continue doing what you're doing
and do as much of it as you want.
If you do 15 minutes, that's good.
If you do a half an hour is good.
You don't have to say I have to do
two hours a day, every little helps.
So I think that's an important part
of, you know, making sure that the
time you spend with the language, you
don't begrudge yourself that time.
You're happy doing it.
And if it's 10 minutes, 20 minutes, half
an hour or two hours, it's all good.
Third problem people have with
language learning is they don't
like to make mistakes and therefore
they are intimidated, intimidated.
So, you know, I always stress input,
but of course we all want to speak.
All, most people want to speak,
and we want to speak with as few
mistakes as possible of course.
However, I like speaking with mistakes...
not that I don't want to improve,
but I know that if I speak
with mistakes, I'm speaking.
And I had a conversation
this morning in German.
I made so many mistakes.
It's been so long since I spoke
German and I speak it so seldom.
In that conversation I
was getting feedback.
I was getting input.
We were communicating.
If I were to do that more,
my German would improve.
Not only because I'm speaking, but
also because I'm getting input back.
And so mistakes are a good thing.
Mistakes are not a bad thing.
Unfortunately, too often, uh, the
traditional language teaching,
you know, instructional methods
teaches us to be afraid of mistakes.
Well, there's nothing wrong with mistakes.
It's not like we're building a bridge
and we might design it wrong and
the bridge is going to collapse.
It's not like that.
If we're communicating, we're
already achieving the main goal
and if we want to improve, but
we're not afraid to make mistakes.
That's the ideal attitude to have.
So, you know, you know you're
speaking with mistakes.
It doesn't bother you
to speak with mistakes.
The other person isn't judging
you, but at the same time, You're
listening to what they're saying.
You're listening to how
the language is used.
You're continuing your input activities.
And so you therefore
are gradually improving.
So I think those would be three major
problems that language learners face.
In other words, they don't
realize that it's a long process.
Number two, they sometimes
begrudge themselves the time
they're spending with it.
Three they're afraid of making mistakes.
And I guess the fourth one, which kind
of summarizes all those three is they're
not finding ways to enjoy the process.
They shouldn't be measuring
how well they're doing.
They should be saying, wow,
I'm enjoying what I'm doing.
And so whatever, however you do that
because you choose content that you
like, or you activities that you like.
If the emphasis is placed on enjoying
the process, you will gradually improve.
So just a brief chat.
And I realized too, and it makes
me happy that many people use my
videos to work on their English.
So I try to speak as clearly as possible.
Okay.
Thanks for listening.
Bye for now.